CIA analyst named it the Caspian Sea
monster
its shape suggests some kind of flying
craft but it's too big to be a regular
plane the length of this thing is
anywhere between 350 400 feet the
wingspan is maybe only 100 feet how is
that going to fly if it's an entirely
new type of flying craft it's twice the
size of the largest commercial airline
built to date the giant 747 such a
machine could deliver an enormous
nuclear payload this is really
frightening the CIA had to get in there
and get more Intel to figure out exactly
what's going on
the CIA Commission's an ambitious new
task force Declassified records reveal
at green lights project aquiline the
development of a top-secret surveillance
program based in area 51 somebody says
hey how about a bird that's really a
drone taking pictures and it says sure
let's do it
well this is actually the start of our
drone program the project aquiline drone
looks like a bird it glides like a bird
but it's the first-ever unmanned
airplane with a camera for a head the
problem is is at this time it was very
difficult to fly such a thing so they
kept crashing it in the tests it was too
risky they couldn't use it for this
eventually continuing reconnaissance
from the corona satellite project yields
the data the CIA analysts need what it
reveals is terrifying
the mystery craft is neither a plane nor
a boat but a deadly hybrid it's a boat
that flies
and it's a boat that flies only a few
feet off the ground a plane moves
forward displaces the air the idea is if
you're close enough to the ground the
air forces back up maintains lift that
was some very simple terms of theory
behind this plane it has the weapons
payload of a ship the speed of a plane
and it's almost impossible to see coming
the most beautiful part about this
design is it flies so low it flies right
underneath radar so when you think about
it this can just appear out of the
middle of nowhere
they could be invading San Francisco in
3 hours and we wouldn't know they were
there until they arrived
it's mind-blowing